Speaker 1: One person that loves what is going
on in terms of the debate around who is the
real president and who should be meeting with
Republicans is Madison Cawthorn. Madison Cawthorn,
unfortunately for him, was caught trying to board
a plane with a gun. And you're not supposed to do
that even if you're a member of Congress. OK,
I don't think if I came to you and I said, sir,
you're sure someone, a member of the House
has tried to board a plane carrying a gun,
would you would you be shocked to learn that that
individual is part of the pro Trump antiscience
wing of the Republican Party? I would not be
shocked by that. And indeed, that is the case. It
is Madison Cauthen, Madison. Cawthorn had his gun
confiscated by airport police. He is now facing
a federal fine, OK, and the loss of a special
security status. This actually happened a few
months ago, February 13th. Cawthorn was already
a member of Congress at the time he went to the
airport, Asheville Airport, North Carolina. TSA
found an unloaded gun in his carry on bag along
with a loaded magazine. Now, defenders will say,
well, but hold on a second. The gun wasn't loaded.
He's still breaking the law. You are allowed to
transport unloaded firearms in a checked bag.
He had a Glock nine millimeter handgun, as
it's described in documents in his carry on,
along with a loaded magazine readily accessible
to him during the flight. That is against the law.
That is an easily loadable gun in the cabin.
Imagine if someone went through security with a
loaded gun and was told, no, no, no, no, you can't
bring it on the plane with you like that. Just
unloaded and then put both parts in the bag and
then you can get on. No, that would never fly.
Now, a spokesman responded to questions saying
this was all just a big mistake. Madison Cawthorn
didn't realize that the gun was there. Now, I'm
going to get to that in a second because that's
actually quite problematic. How frequently does
this happen this year? So far, eight firearms were
reported at the checkpoint. No criminal charges
were filed in any of those cases. What happened
with Madison Catherines gun is that it was secured
at the airport and he got it after his flight.
There actually some recordings an officer can be
heard repeating a few times to another officer.
There's a gun elected official with a
gun, an elected official with a firearm.
Police then have a conversation about what to do.
At one point, they say maybe have him take it out
to his car. He only apparently had seven minutes
before his flight. So they said, we'll hold on to
it for you, will secure it. You can get it when
you come back. I'm glad they made everything so
convenient for him. Right now, different airports
in different states have different rules.
TSA spokesman Mark Powell said in New York they
put. Walk you out of the airport in handcuffs,
on the other hand, in Georgia, you can open
carry anywhere. This took place in Asheville
in nearby Charlotte, North Carolina. Police
normally charge people with guns under a city
ordinance. It's not totally clear what typically
happens in Asheville. It's not yet clear whether
Madison Cawthorn got special treatment. Now, it's
definitely possible that this was an accident.
At the same time, Madison Cawthorn is one of two
or three members of Congress who were prominently
bragging around the time of the Trump riots
that they are armed on the floor of the House
to protect themselves, where guns are also not
allowed. So in order to believe that this was an
accident or an oversight, first of all, we have
to believe that the guy who knowingly brings his
guns where they aren't allowed the floor of the
House unknowingly did the exact same thing when
it came to the cabin of an airplane. OK, so you
tell me what you believe as far as that goes. But
there's another issue. This is not an example of
responsible gun ownership. What I mean by that is
gun owners should know at all times where
is each firearm rather than being unaware
that you've got a gun in your back, because if
you're unaware whether the gun is in your bag,
you might be unaware that one of your guns is
loaded and you're supposed to know the status
and location of every single gun you have
at every time. My friends who have firearms
have theirs locked unless in transit or in use.
If you're careless with them, that's how you get
accidental injury and death. So if the true story
is Cawthorn really didn't know the gun was in his
carry on, that's not responsible because he
was unaware of the location of his firearm.
So a whole bunch of questions here. It also
raises questions about he was intending to fly,
was he flying to a different state? What was
his relationship to a license to have the gun
in that other state, or was he flying from
Asheville to somewhere in North Carolina?
We just don't know all of the answers here yet.
But we're supposed to believe it was all just
a big mistake. Nothing to worry about, no big
deal here, except, you know, he also claims to
have brought guns on the floor of the House, which
you're not allowed to do, really disturbing stuff.